let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 starting today with John in Rhode
Island John and Rhode Island what's
going on John blue yes that's you oh hey
how's it going good
I saw your video I guess the end of
college or whatever or something like
that uh-huh
so I wasn't ask you um I'm just asking a
purely out of curiosity what do you
think of self-education is that good or
bad
itself education is not objectively good
or bad there's two things I would say
about it in John I don't know if you've
got us on some kind of speakerphone
thing but there there's something going
on over there that's very very
distracting banging and wind noises
there's nothing bad about self-education
objectively there's two issues one is as
a society if jobs require certain
educational achievements that are sort
of adjudicated by a third party which is
essentially what colleges and
universities are you might learn just as
much from self education but you won't
necessarily have the credential that
society might say you need to get a
particular job the other thing is there
is something to be said for learning
from experts and what people can teach
you and the fact that reading things in
books is different than being able to
interact with experts and learn in a
different way Oh potentially uh being
true I was just curious what your
thoughts were on that that's all I just
figured you know since a lot of people
have argued oh well you know it's better
or it's working or whatever I personally
think it depends on the job you're
calling for it that's just me personally
right okay John will think they'll seem
busy so I'm gonna let you go but hope to
hear from you again a lot going on there
let's go to our caller from the
five-seven zero area code who's calling
today from 5-7 zero
the business excuse me this is Casey
thank you so much for putting me on it's
a real honor to talk to you today good I
I have a real question I have a real
question for today Dave okay real is I
was here what about tease me now go
ahead I was kidding all right all right
buddy um I know Jimmy Carter has been
involved a lot with the guinea worm
eradication and I'm also familiar with
the principle that the more you do
something the actual like less returns
you get on it the diminishing value
diminishing marginal returns yeah that's
absolutely right so but my question was
do you think it's actually worth it for
mr. Carter to continue doing what he's
doing with the guinea worm you try to
eliminate it even though it does have a
marginal marginal value like the further
you go down what do you think that's an
exception for the eradication of a
disease the other can come back so I I
do think that as a general principle
sometimes economic principles don't
necessarily inform what should be done
once we consider humanity so for example
getting rid of 99% of a disease is quite
different than getting rid of 100% of it
and in that case the additional marginal
cost of that that one last 1% would be
justified as far as the guinea worm and
Jimmy Carter specifically I don't know
enough about that in in in specific
terms to really be able to say anything
beyond that well he's been doing great
work with it the only real problem that
I was getting it eliminated and some of
these war-torn African countries where
it's actually pretty unsafe to go in and
most of the cases now are just didn't
cats and dogs not even humans so it's
really great to see the progress he's
made on that and it's great to support
that foundation all right appreciate it
great to hear from you Jimmy Carter's
work very good